depuis 46 ans deux hommes clament leur
innocence après trois procès d'assises
de cassation une grâce présidentielle
une réhabilitation et une première
demande de révision rejetée
raymond mis et gabriel thiennot condamné
en 47 à 15 ans de travaux forcés pour le
meurtre d'un garde chasse ses deux
hommes ont joué aujourd'hui leur
dernière carte pour obtenir ce que la
justice leur rendre leur honneur pour
reprendre leur expression
la commission de révision se prononcera
le 5 mars rappel des faits avec maryse
burgot philippe du repos ce matin ils
n'en revenaient pas d'être à ce point
demande et 46 ans de combat valait
pourtant bien quelques photos 46 ans que
raymond miss et gabriel thiennot clament
leur innocence
ce matin devant la commission de
révision des procès ils jouaient leur
dernière chance mis et thiennot n'avait
pas 20 ans quand leur nom défraya la
chronique
c'était juste après la guerre on les
accusés du meurtre d'un garde-chasse une
histoire de braconnage un crime qu'ils
disent n'avoir avouer que sous la
torture des gendarmes
c'était en 47 derrière les murs de la
mairie de mézières-en-brenne depuis miss
a quitté la région métiers nos vies
toujours là sur cette paire d'être
hantée où fut retrouvé le corps du
garde-chasse gracié par le président
coty
après huit ans de prison miss et
thiennot compte encore derrière leur
honneur perdu
plus qu'on fasse ce qu'on doit se dire
aujourd'hui tout le village est derrière
miss et thiennot convaincus de leur
innocence
car des témoignages en leur faveur il y
en a comme celui de juliette
à l'époque la fille du fermier brunet
lui confia que c'était son père le
meurtrier
il aurait tué le garde après une
discussion politique qui aurait mal
tourné
je dirais même plus que ça à me disent
ils il a tiré deux ou plus ils vendent
dans l'apport de la fenêtre de la
chambre ne croyant pas l'avoir fait ils
acquièrent les deux autres à la force de
la foi en la sortie de là
pendant des années juliette a gardé ce
secret parce que dit elle
elle avait peur des gendarmes témoignage
tardif donc mais qui jette le doute sur
la culpabilité de miss et thiennot ce
qui pourrait inciter la commission de
révision a accepté que la sphère soit
rejugée 46 ans après en angleterre il